okay the back story with the Roy Moore
sexual assault allegations of course for
accusers accusers of Roy Moore one of
them under Alabama's age of consent she
was 14 years old the age of consent 16
years old now there have been some
defenders and some doubters people
saying things like hey three of these
four would have been legal anyway which
is kind of a weird way to defend child
sex assault in my mind but we now have
another accuser that has come forward
and this one is not saying that she was
involved in a consensual situation with
Roy Moore Beverley young nelson of
alabama is accusing Roy Moore of
sexually assaulting her when she was 16
years old if true this would be two
instances of unwanted sexual contact
with Roy Moore she was a waitress at the
Old Hickory house Moore would come in
Moore offered her a ride home when her
boyfriend was running late and instead
of actually driving her home she says
Moore drove her behind the restaurant
park the car and sexually assaulted her
without consent while she struggled and
protested her lawyer Gloria Allred says
that she's willing to answer questions
about this incident under oath and of
course the fact that Gloria Allred is
involved immediately is setting off the
right they are saying Oh Gloria Allred
is a bomb thrower she's leading a
witch-hunt she's responsible for the
millions of abortions that have taken
place because of her support for roe v
wade can you imagine Beverly Nelson
young can't be believed about her
allegations against Roy Moore because
her lawyer believes that abortion should
be legal and was an activist for that
cause forty years ago guys he admitted
to dating sixteen year olds while he was
in his 30s he's been against statutory
rape laws as a judge is it crazy to
think that a 32 year old who date's
sixteen year old would try to be with a
14 year old and maybe try to pull a fast
one on a 16 year old by driving her
behind the restaurant and we have also
learned that Roy Moore was banned from a
local mall minoo where this is going to
bottom out Roy Moore apparently would go
hang out at the Gadsden Mall in Alabama
he was a regular there kind of like a
mall rat or something he would hang out
there
and multiple people who told The New
Yorker that he would be there alone and
was ultimately banned from the mall
because he was badgering teenage girls
which just sounds about right it's all
part of the exact same thing that we've
been hearing so the only question I have
is is Roy Moore going to resign we've
heard from a number of Republicans now
that it's time for Roy Moore to step
aside and really the reason I'm not
optimistic that this is actually going
to destroy his election chances are that
in the end the President of the United
States was accused by a dozen or more
women of sexual assault including a 13
year old girl right can the so-called
moral majority Christians admit that
they don't really care about their
so-called family values what they care
about is winning elections in order to
impose their Christian worldview on
everybody else if we can get them to
admit that because that's what a lot of
them are thinking we might understand
why this still might not signal the end
for Roy Moore and we will ultimately see
what happened happens more is being hurt
in the polls we talked about that
yesterday he is being asked implored to
resign even by some Republicans but I
don't know that he will and will
continue following it we'll see if more
allegations surface